c'est une action sportive et solidaire
du 30 mai au 1er juin pendant le
week-end de la pentecôte se déroulera la
deuxième édition des coureurs ont du
coeur un événement au profit d'unicef
france et pour en parler avec moi deux
invités anne avril bonsoir la directrice
générale adjointe d'unicef france c'est
également avec nous samuel bonaudo
bonsoir bonsoir de sb consult vous êtes
l'organisateur de la course déjà malgré
le contexte dans ce contexte sanitaire
que l'on connaisse c'est une évidence
pour vous de reproposer cette édition
une deuxième édition des kora van du
coeur cette année après la première
opération qu'on a mis en place au début
mais c'était pas forcément notre voeu de
le faire une deuxième opération mais on
a eu en a qu'un petit sondage par
rapport à nos participants et 99 % des
participants de la première édition nous
demander de reconduire une deuxième
opération donc sous cette île d'inde
on va dire de motivation on a on a
reconduit une seconde opération est un
qui avec ministre alors les coureurs
pourront parcourir des distances d'un 5
ou 10 km en formule aussi speed trait
sur 1h30 ou en enduro trade sur trois
heures voilà plusieurs parcours qui sont
proposés et vous inciter à bien
respecter les mesures gouvernementales
la distanciation physique notamment tout
à fait aujourd'hui les règles ont changé
par rapport à la première édition
mais il ya quand même encore des règles
bien entendu il ya des zones encore
interdite au public donc là ma femme
dior on n'hésite pas du tout et on
demande aux participants d'en respecter
ses hésitations et aussi de respecter
les zones distance station parfois rocco
alors on était petits groupes de 10
personnes maximum avec pas mal de dos
quittent contrainte mais qui sont
beaucoup plus souples que sur la
première édition c'est pour ça que l'on
imagine
l'édition déroule sur plusieurs jours et
sans horaires précis 1 c'est vraiment
pour ne pas créer on peut dire
d'attroupement qui est plusieurs
coureurs en même temps sur le même
parcours oui tout à fait en trois jours
pour le faire on peut le faire le matin
midi le soir chacun trouve son créneau
le plus haut possible le plus facile est
bien entendu ça ne gênera pas recours au
même endroit en avril quelle est
l'importance de ce genre d'événement
pour unicef france qui on le rappelle
oeuvre à la protection des enfants les
plus vulnérables cet événement a une
double vocation le premier c'est de je
pense dans un pays où big unique s'est
fait aussi besoin de vous pour
intervenir dans cette crise je voudrais
dans quelques instants
et puis c'est aussi une attraction ou
des baies en faveur de la cause des
enfants et que est ce que cette crise
par bondues kovy de 19 à fragiliser
davantage la situation des enfants en
france puisque là on parle de la france
mais aussi dans le monde
absolument cette crise l'art les enfants
n'étaient pas à l'école victime est
leader de cette crise mais elle a fait
beaucoup de victimes caché chez les
enfants notamment les enfants les plus
vulnérables en france moi j'avais quitté
pour les big wheel ou situation de
précarité extrême et avec notre
partenaire action contre la faim on
s'est attachés justement aller chercher
secrètement aller chercher ce que ça me
pue le verra l avenir et sa part des
kits d'hygiène cher pour beaucoup de ces
familles c'est à une autre
notre première action de ce que j'ai dit
est ensuite intervenu aussi rassuré le
plus éducatif dans des conditions très
difficiles en parle pas parce que la
côte et le droit à la connexion n'est
pas tout à fait pour tout prix à
l'international
oui aller à l'international
à l'internât ce mammouth évidemment
c'est une situation un petit peu
d'histoire
selon les pays dans 190 pays mais là le
principal attrait de ces le retard de
soins accepte cette catastrophe
enfin cette pandémie notamment dans la
vaccination dans l'accès aux soins dans
l'accès à la santé prénatal et tous on
estime que ça pourrait causer la mort de
6000 enfants c'était le cas chaque jour
je sais pas s'il aurait accepté style
approcha qu on précise je les ai pas dit
au début de cette interview que
l'intégralité des frais de participation
c'est à dire 5 euros par coureur sera
reversée à l'unicef france quels types
d'actions vont pouvoir être financée
grâce grâce à ses dons alors des zac de
façon très concrète du matériel du
matériel de protection en france qu'on a
une partie des besoins mais on
s'assurera que les personnes à qui on en
a distrait la chaîne d'approvisionnement
pour compte continuera on note
d'ailleurs distribués aux hôpitaux
parisiens
et puis évidemment l'international ce
sont essentiellement les kits d'hygiène
des masques et évidemment tout le
matériel de protection peut être les
soignants aux besoins et d'août il
manque cruellement au début de cette
pandémie
et si on fait l'état des lieux des dons
est ce que en cette période sanitaires
ils ont été en recul peut-être d'autres
d'autres causes peut-être des des
hôpitaux qui ont été aussi financé
pendant cette période parce que les dons
pour unicef france ont été en recul
pendant cette période sanitaires alors
écoutez non non non et je suis très très
heureux parce que comme toujours les
français au magnifique élan de
solidarité sont traités dans ce cas là
évidemment des personnels soignants qui
étaient en première ligne et c'est tout
à fait normal mais une premier les
enfants mais l'action ni sa faisait qui
était peut-être un peu plus dans l'ombre
ceux qui n'ont pas condamné leur soutien
pour des enfants
internet ronald duman constaté des taux
va dire est assez comparable toi
derrière aux années précédentes
alors on a commencé cette interview avec
vous samuel bonaudo valeurs terminent
avec vous il ya déjà cinquante neuf
inscrits sur le département des yvelines
qui nous intéressent directement très
concrètement comment s'inscrit ton et
surtout comment participent tous à ceux
à cet événement alors pour rappeler l'on
peut y participer en courant ou en
marchant allait beaucoup de marcheurs de
randonneurs ou marcheurs sur la première
révision et pour vous engager vous allez
sur le site les coureurs ont du coeur
point com et vous aurez tous les
renseignements pour pouvoir vous engager
les inscriptions sont bien entendu
ouverte
oui c'est vrai car villes de france m'a
énormément de participants sur la
première édition c'était la région qui
était le plus représenté votre
département soit 18 est un des
départements les plus sûrs les plus
dynamiques avec la première édition donc
on va voir faire un deuxième est votre
département
et comment quels sont les objectifs
pendant que vous fixé pour pour cette
deuxième édition à la et et 21000 un peu
plus de vingt mille participants sur la
première on espère qu'à minima chaque
participante qui avait couru la première
addition puisse ramener une personne qui
l'avait pas fait donc on aimerait bien
mais a minima doubler le nombre de
personnes c'est notre challenge
aujourd'hui voilà aujourd'hui mais comme
la première fois et ça va se mobiliser
d'ici la fin de la semaine donc mettez
vos baskets
ouais il marcher courir kilomètres km 10
km pour des spécialistes
on va avoir le maximum et pour voir où
versé le maximum et c'est tout
prochainement c'est du 30 mai au 1er
juin toutes les informations à retrouver
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
merci un abri merci samuel bonaudo
d'avoir été avec nous merci avec passi
au revoir merci